as was mentioned in the description that
was published uh obviously you need to
be somewhat familiar with either Jupiter
notebooks or Jupiter lab I myself had
only used Jupiter notebook for years uh
so just in case you were like me and
only use Jupiter notebook this is
Jupiter
lab um you have uh a panel over here
that can be opened and closed has a file
browser I can uh for example open up a
notebook over here and look at the
notebook I have these various tabs that
can be moved around uh we can open up
multiple
notebooks uh we can run other things
over here this part here is called the
command pallet which we'll talk about a
little bit as we use it this can be
expanded can be closed like that and so
forth so that's Jupiter lab
and obviously Jupiter notebook is uh
like this notebook over here
um so I'm going to go through the entire
tutorial so that you get the big picture
see the whole tutorial um all the
various building and compiling and stuff
like that I have screenshots so it'll go
faster we'll get through it faster and
then when I'm done in about 35 minutes
you can open your laptops and I'll show
you I'll put up a
um very step byep exactly what you need
to do to run through the tutorial okay
so as I mentioned this is what Jupiter
lab looks
like uh so basically I'll go through the
code I'll explain the code I'll demo the
code you can watch feel free to ask
questions throughout and then at the end
as I just said uh you can code it
yourself uh these were the prerequisites
you should be familiar with Jupiter
notebooks or Jupiter lab uh you need to
understand uh classes objects
inheritance a little bit um and you need
to have miniconda or some version
thereof installed on your laptop to be
able to do the
tutorial um a little bit about uh the
company I work for Bloomberg uh we
provide all these services to about 300
a little more than
350,000 uh Financial Market
professionals and we provide financial
news to the public via television radio
and online we have over 21,000 employees
over 8,000 of them are software
Engineers so that's literally more than
a third of the company of software
Engineers we've already engineering
Centric uh there's about 4,500 Engineers
who are involved with python um and uh
at Bloomberg we contribute to and we use
and we sometimes sponsor open source
projects uh such as uh such as this one
and we are h iring if you're interested
go to bloomberg.com careers we're also
going to have a booth here tomorrow in
the next day if you're interested and a
little bit about me as was mentioned I'm
an engineer at Bloomberg I uh I've done
a lot of you know full stack stuff but I
probably spent most of my time doing CNC
Plus+ on the server side about five
years ago I started doing a lot of
python and Jupiter notebooks uh I'm a
big open source Advocate at Bloomberg uh
pushing for its use and and and contri
butions I'm also the maintainer as was
mentioned of the npl finance package
within the M plot log organization I was
a member of the charter financial
analyst Institute for about 10 years and
I started my career a long time ago in
molecular biophysics so little bit of
vocabulary before we start the tutorial
an NB extension is the classic notebook
extension uh these are the extensions
for the old Jupiter notebook uh they are
being being defecated this style of
making extensions the new style of
extensions is called lab extension they
work in Jupiter lab and they also work
in Jupiter notebook version seven and
higher at lumino and at Jupiter lab are
npm package scopes of typescript and
JavaScript packages we'll be using both
of these package Scopes in the
tutorial um a plugin plugin is the class
that provides the extension
functionality in Jupiter lab the
beginning of any writing any extension
is to declare an instance of the plug-in
class and then you customize it the way
you want for your extension so now we
can define an extension an extension is
a package that can be installed that
contains one or more
plugins a token is uh an instance of the
lumino token class and it's basically an
identifier that identifies a service
provided by a plugin and we'll see
tokens also throughout the uh
tutorial the lumino package scope has a
concept of the command registry and this
is utilized inside the Jupiter uh front
end application it has a a property
called commands and that is a command
registry it's basically just a list of
command names associated with functions
but it's the way that you can set up uh
various functions that can be called
anywhere within from within jupyter lab
by accessing the command registry a
widget is basically everything you see
on the Jupiter lab screen
they're all um derived from lumino
widgets and JPM uh stands for the
Jupiter lab packaging manager which
we'll be using in the tutorial is
basically Jupiter's version of the yarn
packaging
manager so the tutorial I broke it up
into about well depending how you count
eight or 10 steps um or 11 um we'll just
go through it quickly here so the first
step is basically to create kind of a do
nothing extension from a template we'll
use the templating uh tool copier it's
similar to cookie cutter if you're
familiar with cookie cutter or some of
the others uh then we'll actually create
a command to the command registry to
actually to to do something and then
we'll execute that command from the
command pallet that was that one of
those side panels that I showed you in
Jupiter
lab uh then we'll modify the command to
actually create create a widget in the
main area of the
screen then we're going to sty the
widget and then we're going to execute
the then we'll see how we can execute
the command from other places within
Jupiter lab not just from the command
pallet maybe from the menu or from the
uh we'll do it from the launcher uh then
we'll see how we can execute the command
with arguments to cause our um extension
to behave differently in different
situations and finally we'll create our
own sideboard widget which kind of like
the launcher which will have multiple
buttons and we can launch our widgets in
different ways based on the
buttons so to start excuse me to start
we have to create a conduit environment
this helps everything to run we're going
to call condic create I named my
environment jlx for Jupiter lab
extension uh this I'm not 100% sure if
this is necessary but it's in the
documentation to use it override
channels strict Channel priority uh
we're going to get our code from cond
Forge our packages from cond of Forge
and we're going to set the node defaults
option meaning if you can't find a condo
Forge don't fall back to any default
values uh we're going to pull in Jupiter
lab version 4 no JS version 18 get
copier version seven and ginger two time
is something that copier needs needs
it's not uh used for Jupiter lab as far
as I know um after you create your
condent environment you activate
it call Condo activate and now we're
ready to start creating our our
extension from the template so the the
syntax is copy or copy then the template
and the destination so we're going to
call copy or cop rate our template is on
GitHub jupyter lab extension template
and I'm naming our extension pyd jlx
stands for pi data Jupiter lab
extension so when you run copier when
you run that copier it basically asks
you a lot of a bunch of questions what
type of extension do you want to do
we're doing a front end extension
there's also a server side extension
uh you can do a theme you want to create
a different theme for Jupiter lab and
things like that so we're going to focus
on frontend extension ask you for
the excuse me for the extension author's
name uh email uh the package name this
is the name of your extension you can
create both a JavaScript package and a
python package we're going to do both
the same name no reason not to uh this
is a a good one does the extension have
user settings if you want we're not
going to do it today because it's a
little more Advanced you can create user
settings for your extension so that each
user can have their own preferences
within your extension uh you can also
set up a binder example so that someone
can just run it uh within binder uh and
you can also set up tests I highly
recommend we're not going to do it today
but I highly recommend if you're doing
something for production to actually
release to other people I suggest you
set up the uh regression test and then
you can have a reposit you can specify a
repository this specification here is
just for documentation as to what the
repository is it goes into the package
when you run that it's going to create a
bunch of
files let's take a look at the files it
created so uh you can see here it
created this directory pyd jlx if I uh
CD into that directory or LS what's in
that directory you can see all the
standard things that you would normally
see that comes with a package you have
your change log your license your readme
file I'm going to focus on a couple of
files in here uh to show what they do so
the first one here is this package.json
file this is the file that
defines your package for the packaging
manager if you look inside the package
I'm sorry what happen here there we go
if you look inside the package.json file
you'll see it's got the name of the
package um version number description
various other things some of the things
that you typed in before uh some files
the
license um and down here there's a
section I want to focus on called the
scripts and when you run the jupyter lab
packaging manager it has a command
called run you run JPM space run and
then you can run any of these scripts
that are defined in the package that
Jason file so some of the scripts will
be running this build script a lot and
it actually does two things the first
thing it does is it runs GPM build live
which is another script down here so you
can see you can reference other scripts
within this script section and excuse me
all this is going to do is a typescript
compile with a source map for debugging
purposes and then it's going to do then
the second part of the build is to do a
JLM build lab extension Dev which is a
script down here and that calls Jupiter
the lab extension command on Jupiter
with build sub command for
development so if you if you page down
there's some more scripts down here I
suggested you get more involved with
this read through the scripts there's a
lot of neat things here that you can use
as tools the other section I wanted to
focus on in this file is this dependency
section this lists all the packages that
your extension is dependent upon and
this simple template extension is
dependent only on the jupyter lab
application itself we'll see later how
we can add other dependencies to this
section of the
file yeah another file in that directory
I want to focus on as you see so we're
in the pyd jlx directory and within that
there's another directory with the same
name this is where our built extension
is going to get put when we build the
extension it goes into this lower level
uh pyd jlx uh
subdirectory another uh file I want to
focus on here is the source directory
the source file for your extension is
called index.ts index.
typescript um um and it looks like this
this is your basic do nothing extension
so the first thing we do we're going to
import the Jupiter front end import
Jupiter front end PL land and we're
reporting both of those from jupyter Lab
application where we dependent on that
package and then here's our plugin that
we said this is the basic extension you
declare a plug-in variable of type
Jupiter frontend plugin and we're going
to set certain properties on this
variable we set an identifier the
identifier is just a unique string
within Jupiter lab there is a convention
to put a colon in the middle of the
identifier somewhere in the identifier
so you're basically scoping your
identifier you have like a scope on the
left and something more specific on the
right the description auto start equals
true means that when Jupiter lab starts
up I want my extension to also start up
what does that mean how does it start up
our extension what that means is it's
going to call our activate function so
here we Define an activate function
we're defining it as an anonymous
function right
here and Jupiter lab will pass in the
Jupiter front end application itself to
our activate function so that we can
interact with it so we're accepting it
here as a variable called app and all
this extension is doing is it's writing
to console.log dupit lab extension pyd
jlx is activated that's all it's doing
for now finally we export the plugin so
the rest of the application can see
it so at this point uh if you want it's
a good time to make you have your your
simple templates uh
extension and so you can create a get
repository just get a it get add dot all
the files and then commit the the files
and then from then on as you make
changes you can make your Miss I'm going
to show you at the end I have a GitHub
repository with the tutorial in it and
each step that we're going to go through
I did another commit so that uh you can
diff and see what the what the diffs are
so in the next step in build to build a
project we have to first install
everything that we're dependent upon and
we said we were only dependent on the
Jupiter lab application itself but that
is dependent on a lot of other things
that we're going to see so JPM install
does not install the extension it
installs what the extension is dependent
upon and it installs it in the
extensions working directly where you do
where you're coding so that all those
dependencies are there to for you to be
able to build so for run JPM install
there's what it looks like you you'll
see this moving for a while it's
rewriting the page over and over here
all the various uh packages uh mine took
about 20 seconds to run to install those
packages after you run that if you LS
the directory you're going to see two
new files going to see yarn. loock file
this is just a text file that lists all
the interdependencies between the
various packages uh nothing really in
there for you to concern yourself about
about but that's what it is and then
this is the important thing you'll see
this node modules directory that's where
all the packages just got installed in
that
subdirectory if you look in that
directory I'm just looking at the top 18
files excuse me directories in that
directory these are all the package
Scopes uh you can see here for example
here's the jupyter lab package scope
that we just talked about the at lumino
package scope uh there's a total of 436
package scops that got installed when I
ran this um and each one could have
anywhere from one to 10 or 20 packages
so there's a lot of code that uh got
installed there quickly if I look inside
one of these for example the Jupiter lab
package scope you see here there are 16
different
packages here's the application package
that we already saw inside the uh inside
the extension and we're also going to
use the app package and and there'll be
some other packages that we'll use later
to
see now that all the sub packages are
installed that we depend on now we run
JPM run build that's that script that we
saw inside the uh inside the package
that Jon file when you run that it looks
kind of like this uh down here you'll
see successfully if it R successfully
we'll see later what this looks like if
in that her if an error
occurs okay so now
we we created our template extension we
installed the dependencies we built the
extension uh now we need to install the
extension so before we install I going
to show you these two commands you on
Jupiter lab extension we saw that
command before had a sub extend a
subcommand build here we're going to run
the subcommand list this will list all
the installed extensions and at the same
time it'll list the directories where it
found them it looks in several different
places and it'll show you where it found
the extensions
and you can LS that directory and
actually see the extension files
installed there uh then we'll do the
install now you could do pip install the
problem with Pip install is that every
time we make a code change you're going
to have to install it again so what
we're going to do instead while we're
developing we'll do Jupiter lab
extension Dev uh develop D- override
just overwrites if there was something
already installed there overr right and
that's going to install it as a symbolic
link back to the directory where we're
working so this means that every time we
make a code change it'll automatically
be there you won't have to reinstall and
then we'll run these two commands again
to see what changed so if you run lab
extension list you can see here I had
only one extension
installed and here it showed me the
directory where that extension was in
installed if I LS that directory I can
see the extension down here there's a
directory and all the all the extension
files are in there so now we run Jupiter
lab extension over
right and uh when we run that it looks
like this it tells me it's installing
then it tells me it's Sim linking now
when I run the list I have two
extensions installed so it did install
correctly and if I LS you can see down
here there's the both directories except
this one that we just installed as a
symbolic link back to where we're doing
our
work at this point you want to test and
see if your extension is actually
working now that it's installed so since
you're working you typically you're
working in one window so you want to
open up another window activate the same
um conduit environment and run Jupiter
lab in the other window and when it
comes up it looks like this but remember
all the extension was doing was writing
to the console so what we want to do is
we want to come over here depending on
your browser this is Chrome if Chrome
you come down to more Tools in developer
tools if you click on that it'll open up
the uh console and you can see right
there it says jupyter lab extension p y
jlx it's
activated so the extension's working
it's activated of course it's not doing
anything but it's it's working being
activated so that was all Step Zero
that's the hardest step in the whole
process all the other steps we're going
to see is just change the code rebuild
refresh the browser um so the next thing
we're going to do we're going to create
a command to actually do something and
again just code build refresh the
browser so here's the code change uh we
were just writing to the console we're
going to leave that write in just so we
can be sure that it's being activated
and so we're going to create a command
ID that's just a string again there is a
convention some people follow to put a
colon in the string so that you can
scope things out in the command registry
and now the command registry is as I
said it was a property on the Jupiter
front end application so we're going to
call app commands we're going to call
add command pass in the command ID and
give the command a couple of uh
attributes we're going to give it a
label hello world and this is the key to
the command is the execute attribute
we're just going to give it a function
called say hello so this basically the
command registry just Associates this
command ID with this function down here
outside all this is inside the activate
function outside of the activate
function we're going to Define our say
hello function and all that's going to
do for now is write to the console
log so run JPM build refresh T lab
browser here here's the build it was
successful uh here's refreshing the
[Music]
browser and now when I refresh the
browser not only do I have that it was
activated but I have uh JL uh jxd says
jlx whatever I wrote in there I forgot
to say one thing pardon me so down here
in the activate function I also on the
command
registry um I called it has an execute
function so I can execute the command
now this normally would not execute the
command from within the activate
function but I'm just doing it here for
testing purposes just to make sure my C
command is
working so coming back to that so now
when we refresh the browser we see the
activate gives the activate uh right and
then it gives it calls the command which
does its own right okay so that was
creating a command now we have a command
now let's execute command from somewhere
else in uh Jupiter lab we're going to do
that from the command pallet and know
that was that part of over on the side
let's see it so to do that we're going
to import I command pallet this is one
of these tokens that we were talking
about it's a service provided by another
plugin and we're going to import that
from jupyter Lab apples and then down
here where we're declaring our plugin
we're going to add a new property called
requires and we're going to say that our
plugin requires the I command pet is
actually in this context where you would
call it a token a lumino token so what
that tells Jupiter lab is don't just
pass the application me into my activate
function I want you to also pass in the
command pet that I'm saying that I
require so it passes in the command
pallet we're going to accept it as a
variable named pallet and the rest of
the activate function here is the same
it's just writing to the console and
it's creating our Command and now down
here we're going to call on pallet add
item we're going to give it the command
ID that we defined up here and I'm going
to give it a category of anything only
because on the command pet everything is
alphabetical and I want it to show up at
the top so it'll be easy for us to
say so we run the build refresh the
browser there's the build it was
successful here's refreshing the browser
now before I refresh the browser we had
this uh hello world here but when I
refresh the browser that disappears
because I'm no longer doing it inside
the activate function remember that was
just for testing purposes but what I do
have here now over in the command pet I
have this new category called anything
and I see Hello world that was the label
that I get
and if I click here on hello world now
it says hello world over here so now I'm
actually executing my command from
somewhere else in
Jupiter all right so let's make the
command actually do something useful
besides just writing to the console
we're going to create a widget in the
Jupiter lab main area this is the main
area here where you see the launcher
it's basically just going to open up a
new tab and we'll have something here
that's where you put your notebooks or
various other things we're going to
create a widget there so here's the code
for that
actually this is the first step in the
code for that all this is showing is our
activate function is going to start
getting pretty busy so all I did was I
split it out it's no longer an anonymous
function I simply said activate call
underbar activate and then down oops
sorry about
that uh and then down here I simply
defined function underbar activate all
the code is the same so there's no
change here except I split out the
activate function as so it's no longer
Anonymous now now um we're going to we
were importing the command pet we're
going to import widget from luminal
widgets we're going to import main area
widget from Jupiter lab apples what
we're going to do is we're going to
derive our own widget from the lumino
widget and then we're going to
instantiate a main area widget putting
our lumino widget inside of it as the
content so that way this main area
widget will have all the properties of
most main area widgets where we can move
it around on the screen and all that
other stuff that we
saw excuse me so here's how we do here's
how we do that we define a class A
Little World widget extends widget uh
all we have to do is Define a
Constructor our Constructor we're going
to call the super to call the parent
class Constructor specify uh an ID for
our class uh this title label we're
going to give it a label hello world and
this thing closable means that the user
we're going to allow the user if he
clicks the X uh that the widget will
close um then we're just going to I'm
just going to use document and create
element I'm going to create a body and a
header and for the header text I'm just
going to say hello world from PI data
I'm going to pin The Heading uh to the
body and then I pen the body to this do
node this do node is this widget
itself okay so put put the body inside
this widget put the header inside the
body so now we have our class but we
have to use it so down here we'll come
up to here in a minute uh down here so
so our hello say hello function was just
writing to the console now we're going
to actually instantiate the hello world
widget uh I'm going to call it content
I'm going instanciate a main area widget
I'm passing the content in uh the hello
world widget now I need to put that
widget on the screen so I need to
interact with the Jupiter lab
application so the application we saw
that it has this command registry it
also has a thing called the shell which
is basically the whole all everything
you see on the
application so on the shell call add and
I'm going to pass in my widget I'm going
to say put it in the main area you'll
see later in the documentation that uh
this could be name it could be top
bottom left right uh there's a couple
other things in there and then I have to
activate my widget this is why we gave
the widget an ID we're going to call
activate by ID to activate the widget
now notice before say hello did not have
any arguments now I need to pass in the
Jupiter lab application so here where
I'm doing execute we'll see later the
execute function can only take a certain
type of argument and we'll see what that
is later so the way to get the
application into my say hello function
is I'm going to create the attribute
function as an anonymous function that
simply calls my say hello function
passing in the
application run the build refresh the
browser there's the
build and now when I refresh the browser
here's my Hello World when I click there
I get a new widget right here see it
says hello world from P data
okay and if I want I can move this
around right can move it around to the
side I can drag it down to the bottom I
can click this again and have another
one okay so that's my widget so
now that was um command creates a widget
now we want to style a widget we're
going to see how styling Works in
Jupiter
life
so uh we didn't look at this directly
before but in in our project directory
there's a subdirectly called style and
in there there's a file called base. CSS
these other files you don't need to
worry about they actually just include
base.
CSS if we edit base. CSS you'll see it
just has a comment in it it tells you
where you can look in the docs for
various useful CSS patterns but all
we're going to do is uh we're going
we're going to uh style the body make
sure it takes up the whole screen center
it give it a color we'll style the
header give it a position part way down
left and right is zero so it'll take off
across the whole screen and I'll
increase the font size so it's easier to
see now notice I'm styling the body and
the header only for a specific CSS class
I invented I made up a CSS class called
uh hww stands for hello world widget
because if I didn't do this I would end
up styling all jup LA and I don't NE I
don't want to do that I only want to
style my widget so that's why I created
this class uh however my widget didn't
have a class so we have to add one line
of code to the Constructor for our
widget we're going to call this. add
class we'll pass in that class hww so
that now we're styling our
widget so now uh with the styled widget
now we going to collect the world well
first we have to run the build and
refresh and I've actually done that
where I forget to I'll change the code
and forget that I have to uh run the
build and refresh but you run the build
and refresh and now we have a style
widg okay so now let's see how we can
execute the command from somewhere else
on uh in Jupiter lab this is the
launcher area over here where we can
launch notebooks and a console and a
terminal and various other
things so to execute the command from
launcher we're going to import ey
launcher the ey launcher token for
Jupiter lab launcher and down here I
could have said where I say requires I
command pilot I could have said comma I
launcher and it would said I require the
launcher also and they're passing the
launcher but what we're doing it turns
out that the
launcher is itself a an extension that
anyone could
disable some people might even have a
fork of Jupiter lab that doesn't have
launcher in it and let's say I want my
extension to work whether or not the
launcher is there if the launcher is
there I'll use the launcher if it's not
there I still want it to work so then I
can say optional ey launcher so what
this tells uh Jupiter lab is anything
that's listed under requires or optional
it's going to get passed into my
activate function but if it's optional
and it's not found it'll pass in null in
that position
instead so here's doing that here's the
activate function uh I'm accepting the
command pallet and accepting launcher as
either an ey launcher or an
all and then down here the rest of the
activate function is the same as it was
before uh creating a
command
um adding the command to the pallet now
we want to add the command to the
launcher so we call launcher. app but
before we do that I have to make sure I
actually have a launcher so I'm going to
say if launcher then launcher. add put
in the command ID I'm using category of
notebook again just I wanted you at the
top of the screen so it' be easy to see
otherwise if I don't have a launcher I'm
just going to write to the console I
launcher is not available
run the build refresh the browser and
now when we run the build we see an
error so here on my import it says I
can't find Jupiter lab launcher so this
is a new package that we need to depend
on we don't have it so what do we do
when we want when we have a new package
we want to depend on um first let me
show you this if you look in the Jupiter
lab uh node modules directory you can
see all the packages that were there and
the launcher package should be here it's
alphabetical and it should be between
doc registry and MB format it's clearly
not there so how do we add it we call
JPM add to add a package so to do that
we're going to call JP mad and then the
package
name it looks kind of like this you can
see it looked very similar to when we
did the install it's basically
installing our
package and now if you look in that
directory now you can see the launcher
it got
installed now notice also if everyone
gets status package.json file has been
modified so what what that JRP M did it
not only installed the launcher it went
into the package.json file and it added
the dependency
there okay so now uh so this is just
summarizing what I just said it installs
it and it adds the edits the uh package
Json file adding the dependency run the
build refresh the browser the build
succeeds this time and now here in the
launcher we have another button right
here that says hello world and if I
click that button I get my widget and if
I click over here on the command pallet
I get the another widget so now I have I
can create my widget from different
places okay so
now uh what if I wanted to know where my
command was being called from one thing
I might want to know so I can pass
arguments in the command to into the
command to see where it came from so
here's how we're going to do that uh so
here uh the execute function as I said
before it can only receive one type of
an argument and that type is a constant
Json object so if I want to receive
arguments to my execute function I'm
just going to give it the variable name
ARs and and say that it has can be
anything but what it will be is a
constant Json function then down here
where I was adding it to the command
pilet I'm going to say ARG and I'm going
to pass in a constant Jon an object I'm
going to pass in an object with the key
of greeting and the value of hello from
the command
pet and notice here in my say hello
function I'm also passing in in addition
to the application I was passing before
I'm now passing in the
ARs so here and say hello I'm receiving
the ARs I'm going to access the greeting
attribute of that Json object if it does
not exist I'm going to get a null here
now one of the things I I forgot to say
over here I could have also done it here
with the launcher I could have said ARs
and passed in ARS from the launcher but
I I chose not to because I want you to
see what it's like with and without
arguments so so I'm now going to pass in
the greetings attribute to my hello
world uh uh widget Constructor so here
in this Constructor I'm going to accept
the string called greeting it's going to
be either a string or null if I get the
string I'm going to set the head inner
text to that reading otherwise I'm going
to set it to the default what we had
before hello world from PI
data okay run the build refresh the
browser now when I click here in the
launcher I get the default hello world
from by data but if I click over here
from the command pallet I get hello from
the command
pallet put those side by side so you can
see
them okay finally the last part which
might break into three steps we're going
to create our own widget over here on
the sidebar with several buttons to
launch our widget in different ways so
I'm going to break it up first we're
going to create a sideboard with uh
buttons um then we'll style it and then
we'll add it then there to the deves so
we're going to declare a sideboard uh
hello widget extends widget it's very
similar to the other widget that we
created uh called the super give it an
ID give it a link label say closable it
goes true we're going to add a different
class because I want to style this one
separately from the other one uh sidebar
hello widget class is what I decided I
created four buttons EFG and H append
the buttons to the body and append the
body to this
s uh then down here outside of the act
or actually still inside the activate
function everything's the same but while
I'm activating it I want to activate
this sidebar widget so let me make that
a little bigger here so you can see so
I'm just declaring a sidebar
widget uh now I'm calling the app shell
add notice now I'm saying I want it on
the left not in the main area but on the
left side and then I activate it so now
we run the build we refresh the browser
looks basically the same anyone see
what's
different on the side it says right over
here on the side May over here on the
side on the side says hello world so
these are all different sidebars here
you remember in the very beginning of
the talk I showed you how there was a
file browser and the command thing if I
click here where it says hello world I
get this new widget that I created with
the EFG andh buttons that's a little cut
off
screen ah I don't know I can change
that maybe that's why you didn't see
H
um all right you basically saw it right
to credit all right so now so now we're
going to style the sideboard widget I'm
not going to go into this we'll save a
little time basically I just made the
buttons bigger and gave it a a similar
background color as the others
um run the build refresh the browser and
now the sideb bar looks like this EFG
image buttons now it's interesting to
know one thing I need to do here to keep
things simple and also because I haven't
done all the research to figure out how
to do that in theory there were already
class in Jupiter lab that I could have
used to derive another sidebar widget so
it would have already probably had the
same background color as the other
sidebars and not only that if I did that
and someone created their own
theme extension then because I derived
from those classes I would inherit the
theme properly but the way I did it now
I would not inherit the theme properly
so you know if you're doing something
really production quality you wouldn't
necessarily do it that way all right so
now let's add event event listeners to
those buttons so they can actually do
something so uh here's my sidebo widget
uh
class um instead of just creating before
buttons I created this record here it's
just a key value mapping of the EF g& to
saying hello world in various languages
and then I'm going to Loop through that
mapping for each element I'm going to
create a button I'm going to set the
inner text to the key and then I'm going
to add an event listener for clicking uh
an anonymous function that's now
remember uh the command registry has an
execute function so I'm going to call
the execute function pass in the command
ID and I'm going to pass in the greeting
from the value of this uh record over
here so I'm going to get a different
greeting for each button now notice in
order to interact with the app I now
need the app in the Constructor of my uh
uh sidebar widget uh and I also need the
command ID so I'm going to accept those
and then down here where I was
instantiating the uh sidebar widget
actually I think I did this on it yeah
so here this is actually a better view
of the class okay here's here's that
record I told you about looping through
button uh passing into
greeting and uh pending the buttons to
the body and the body to the node and
then down here where I instantiate the
sidebar hello widget I'm now passing in
the app and the command ID and we're
still putting it on the left and so
forth run the build refresh the browser
and now I have my four buttons If I
click the first one I get hello world uh
if I click the f I get
Bon G is
Al I'm not sure how to pronounce that
and
shom okay and that is uh basically the
end of the tutorial so if you want uh
you can open up your laptops I'm going
to show you where you can see the steps
there's a couple other things here I'm
going to go through maybe after you're
working for a little bit I'll go through
the uh some of the documentation here on
these other
slides but the first thing I want you to
do so here if you go to my GitHub
repository so it's github.com see that
that's big enough make it a little
bigger uh github.com danani Goldfarb pyd
jlx
so down here in the read
me I broke this up into two parts for
Step Zero follow the detailed substeps
below it'll show you that in a minute
and then for steps one through seven
again we're just going to make a code
change indicated in the code change
section run the build refresh the
browser and test so here's Step
Zero uh all those commands that I ran
just step by step cond to create cond to
activate copier CD into the directory
take a look at the files run the get a
nit
um and so forth and down here here's the
code changes for each step so for
example if you click on step one it's
going to take you to the GitHub dip for
that code change uh I clip on any of
these other steps again it takes you to
the GI
upate when it got to the slide where we
created the widget just put up that
first widget that just said hello world
at that point that's where you can build
an application right you can use any
browser based technologies that you want
you can use react you can use uh
typescript whatever you want there to
build whatever application you want
right there in that widget so um let's
uh let me take a few minutes of your
time and we'll go over some of the
documentation um that I list here at the
end of the slide by the way the uh this
um GitHub repository that has the
tutorial in it with and uh you know you
go down here where I created links to
all the diffs or or alternatively you
can click here where it says 13 commits
and then if you just click on any of
those commits you'll see the diff that
was for that step and the commit usually
indic case what the step was over here
um but also in this repository there's a
file right here slides.pdf those are the
slides of the presentation I just gave
you um and down here in the read me
obviously distes the specific steps uh
right now um
anyway so uh the last couple slides um
let me go
into slides
and we'll go over the a little bit of
the documentation so this one the
extension developer
guide um is right here there's a lot to
read all about how to develop extensions
I think having gone through my tutorial
it'll help you a bit um to read this and
understand it um also within
here uh is this idea of core tokens uh
these are the co tokens we saw some of
these for example we
saw um well here is IAB shell that's the
shell we talked about um what what did
we see in here we
saw
um we saw the launcher here's ey
launcher right so these are the core
tokens and I want to talk point out a
couple of them that we didn't use that
might be of interest to you for example
this one I layout
restorer um this is a service that you
can use so that uh you may have noticed
if you're using Jupiter lab and you have
a notebook open when you close Jupiter
lab and you reopen Jupiter lab The
Notebook is still open so that's called
the layout restore so if you have your
own extension and you want it also to be
restored when Jupiter lab stops and
restarts you can use this um Service as
a way of restoring the layout of
your um of your extension let's see what
else is interesting here here's the
command pallet which we
use
uh what else there's a several in here
let me see if I can find one of them
there were several in here called
trackers like here's the editor tracker
there's the at HTML viewer tracker the
image tracker um there's a notebook
tracker so the tractors are good uh if
if you want your extension for example
suppose you wrote a spell check
extension where you spell check
everything in a notebook you might want
to have your extension use the notebook
tracker to know every time a notebook
was changed and then you go back and re
spell check it again so that's what the
trackers do so there's all kinds of
services here available to you as an
extension writer that you can uh
use um let's see what else that I want
to talk about the front end shell this
is the uh thing I was talking about
before when you're creating a widget we
used main put it in the main area we
also use left you can see there's top
there's menu for the menu items uh
there's left and right down and bottom
I'm not sure what the differen is
between down and bottom I guess the
bottom is the lower part with status
bars and have now some of these when we
did left and we did main all you have to
do is add your WID
but some of them require that your
widget or how you're adding it be a
specific structure for example the menu
um requires a very and the documentation
will show you how requires a very
specific structure that you pass into it
um so that it knows what menu to put you
want to put it in um there is another
tutorial here in the Jupiter lab
documentation this is called the random
astronomy picture uh there's a couple
things you can learn from this that you
didn't like learn from mine and there's
a couple things in mind that you don't
learn from this one of the things for
example in this in mind every time you
click the command you got a new widget
on the screen one of the things they do
here is they teach you well suppose I
only want one and if the person clicks
it again just bring it into Focus bring
it to the foreground if in case it was
in the background so it teaches you how
to do that um it also teaches you how to
do um uh inside Jupiter lab uh promises
which is um JavaScript for uh
asynchronous Communications because this
this tutorial has you going off to some
NASA website to get a random astronomy
picture um let's see what else do we
have here um and then there's this
extension examples repository under
Jupiter lab uh there's a lot of simple
very simple code of different ways of
doing like here's a main menu example if
you want to know how can I book my
extension into the main menu you take a
look at the code for this example you
basically have to clone it build it to
see how it works um there's not a lot of
documentation Within These examples the
code itself is the documentation here's
the
launcher uh that's how I learned to use
the eye launcher and there's a few other
uh things here here you can learn how to
do signals within your uh to accept and
send signals in your
extension uh what else do we have here
uh here's the core just a couple of core
tokens that are interesting as I
mentioned before there's the settings
registry uh you can have uh user
settings for your extension and The
Trackers I already mentioned the L
restore I already mentioned and uh
that's it and we are
hiring